now polls have just closed in Turkey's
local elections they're the first since
the reform package gave president red
chip type air21 sweeping new powers
polls suggest his ruling AKP RT is set
for major losses however his popularity
has been hurt by the country's economic
recession joining us now from Istanbul
is DWS Dorian Jones
Dorian can you help us understand a
little better just how are these
elections a test for president air
dawuan well he's made it a referendum
about his rule in fact he said the whole
country's future is at stake in one of
his last rallies here in Istanbul and
why is attaching so much importance to
these elections is because the control
of the towns and cities across Turkey is
one of the last areas of power that the
president directly doesn't control on
top of that the president is aware that
he's our party's vice-like grip control
of the capital Ankara and Istanbul is
now facing a major challenge from the
opposition and the reason why is that
the country is feeling incredible
economic pain soaring food prices
running at over 30% is fueling public
anger on the streets and the fear among
earth-1 and his ruling parties that they
could be punished by the voters
particularly in key cities like Istanbul
and Ankara and there is his old
political adage in Turkey he who
controls his tambul controls Turkey
another one is aware of that because
that is where his rise to power started
when he was elected mayor in 94 and that
is why he's desperately determined to
prevent his grip on control of these
cities being ended do we have any
indications yet about the elections
being free and fair well certainly in
the last few elections the opposition
have create foul on many occasions of
exciting voting irregularities although
the the ruling AKP does deny this and
again there is concern about the
fairness of the elections there's a
great lot of vigilance a lot of
observers watching very carefully but it
has to be said up until now there has
not been any reports of major egregious
actions suggesting that the Falls are
unfair although it has to be said the
key point is now where we're entering
the counting of the votes that is where
there is the most contentious period and
where there is a great deal of tension
now about whether the votes will be
fairly counted speaking of tension we've
heard reports
two people were shot dead at a polling
station in the eastern city of Malaysia
can you tell us more about that well
that's right
it happened an incident observers from a
fringe Islamic party in a pony opposing
party toured on the Saadat party they
got into a dispute over how some votes
were being cast that quickly
deteriorated into violence resulting the
deaths of two of the the Saadat parties
observers being killed there's been a
great deal of reaction to this apparent
Turkish president one had said he's
regretting I was expressing great deal
of regret that's have all the other
opposition parties but it has to be said
such incidents are not unusual in
Turkish elections and up until now it
has been the only fatal incident that we
have heard of okay DWS Dorian Jones and
Istanbul thank you for that